15-0 mesdames messieurs dans 15 0 le
vrai journal tous les dimanches à 12h40
sur canal+ ça marche comment karl
le vrai journal très bien ça m'a bien
ouais ouais ça fait combien de parts de
marché et coûte 10 en moyenne c'est à
dire mais c'est la même chose depuis des
années quoi c'est un public qui est
extrêmement fidèle sur canal en clair
c'est énorme c'est quatre fois plus que
les autres as tu veux dire du mal de
canard au fait pas le [ __ ] quoi
écoutent ils ont essayé de trouver des
nouveaux animateurs ça marche pas mal
quand même me souviens taux d audience
de nulle part ailleurs grande époque
ainsi en faisait 2 % à l'époque quand
même crié au génie mais 11 et 2 % et les
siens le problème c'est que maintenant
tout le monde a les vrais chiffres quoi
c'est à dire que même les chauffeurs de
taxi bouddhiste semaine dernière vous
avez fait que que 28 1 6 mais qd
connaissent tout maintenant est
tellement d'émission sur lui oui ce
rallye et puis on communique beaucoup
sur les chiffres bon alors vous pensez
quoi justement au coeur de la grille de
canal de rentrée c'est terrible ça
j'étais l'autre con là
bas
auquel
l'autre con non canal ou quoi
alors ça se passe comment la nouvelle
ville de kehl rentrée la très très bien
maintenant langue de bois je mets en
langue de bois te mets pas si le mois de
mai qui l'interviewent des hommes
politiques pour essayer de les faire
sortir non mais j'ai beaucoup ri comme
ça j'ai tout vient de là bas il a appris
la langue de bois diala vous ne vous
fasse vrai pour 5 de bois non mais
sérieusement vous pensez quoi de la
nouvelle grille de canal avec l'autre
con
écouter thierry tout à fait sérieusement
je pense que c'est une bonne grippe
c'est une marie d'avenir que c'est une
grille d'espoir que c'est une grille non
je pense qu'ils ont fait tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient pour essayer de redonner un
peu de brillant du string à canal+ ils
sont en bonne voie ce qui manque en fait
c'est un peu l'esprit canal voilà mais
ils vont ils m'ont promis qu'ils vont
essayer
tu
as promis ça change tout le temps non ça
change pas c'est le changement dans la
continuité
vient alors 4-0 maintenant des choses
vraiment sérieuses vous n'avez pas de
problèmes d'argent c'est un petit peu
comme didot
vous avez vendu votre société de
production à endemol dans 50 % seulement
c'est énorme c'est énorme c'est déjà
beaucoup d'argent endemol la société qui
fait love story la star ac' enfin la
boîte d'arthur ça laisse de quoi vivre
d'avoir vendu 50 % endemol j'imagine oui
c'est un peu la même chose qui est
arrivé à votre ami fogiel voilà
justement comment se fait-il que vous
êtes associé avec fogiel dans le même
groupe endemol et vous l'attaquez au
tribunal sinon je n'ai jamais attaqué en
référé
parce que dans une de ses émissions il y
avait l'ineffable maître collard qui
j'avais payé pour la fameuse lettre
d'allègre va envoyer 15 millions quinze
mille euros voilà vous attaquez le
tribunal quelqu'un qui fait partie de la
même du même groupe que vous si vous
taxez les caisses dire des conneries
c'est mon rôle de l'attaqué mois après
quand il m'a appelé il m'a dit soit
corporate lui ai dit non tu allé trop
loin donc normal que je t'avais vous
attaquez votre votre associé à un
support mon associé
associés dans le groupe jeu lattaque jeu
lattaque ont fait un référé je plaide la
présomption d'innocence et je me fait
retoquer parce qu'on dit mais vous
n'êtes pas mis en examen il fallait pas
plaider sa fin avait plaidé la
diffamation donc je vais réattaquer non
plus changeant d'avocats mais collard
nous en gardons le même mais collard en
diffamation oui bon ça c'est que tu as
autant de succès que tu es si jeune
on
reprend les choses 2 020 alors le 1er
juin carl concentrez-vous parce que là
c'est sûr mais jouer un calage non le
1er juin donc vous lisez 15,0 à
l'antenne du vrai journal une lettre de
patrice alègre le fameux coup de
serial-killer toulza a tellement nourrir
en dix ans est parlante pourquoi t'es
mort de rayon elle faisait découvrir les
serial killers silence des agneaux et
montre le fait un but cirio leader
toulousain où il reconnaît deux jours
après avoir dit aux juges pour la
première fois les meurtre d'une
prostituée d'un travesti qui était
également prostituées absolue bois est
ce que vous lisez la lettre exactement
comme elle a été écrite non je retire
les noms des noms c'est à dire bye bye à
des noms de personnes mis en cause ouais
je ne dis pas à l'antenne ensuite la
presse le lendemain dans le monde on
lira les noms et puis après tout on va
embrayer paris match le figaro etc vous
quand vous lisez l'algérie monsieur truc
monsieur bidule c'est à dire quand on
reçoit la lettre en fait on montre la
lettre à la chaîne qu'est ce que vous en
pensez on fait venir le service
juridique les avocats tout le monde se
pose des questions est ce qu'on dit les
noms et ce qu'on dit pas les noms décide
de ne pas dire les n'ont donc jamais
monsieur truc monsieur bidule il faut il
faut reconnaître d'ailleurs tu vous
vilipendez à l'instant la direction de
canal+ mais faut reconnaître quand même
à ce moment là c'est quand même chaud il
accepte de lire cette lettre est
derrière c'est vrai les le nom va sortir
mais personnellement moi je ne donne pas
le nom lennon en question d'accord vous
n'avez pas est donné ce soir d'emblée
toute façon en voiture et ce tout le
monde les connaît ils en voulaient se
procurer comment cette lettre est bien
très simplement j'avais un journaliste
qui était en train d'enquêter sur cette
affaire alègre 1,12 me balling dit j'ai
une lettre d'allègre qu à l'aigre ta
adressées je lis fac slam wa inna facs
je la lis je tombe de ma chaise je le
rappelle judy rentre on va on va faire
une réunion avec canal avec la direction
et on va voir ce qu'on en fait quite a
envoyé sa à toi lorsque j'ai compris
c'est que il avait envie d'une tribune
médiatique et que ces tribunes
médiatiques qui pensaient que la
meilleure tribune possible pour lui
c'était le vrai journal parce que c'est
une émission qu'il avait pris l'habitude
de regarder en prison comme beaucoup de
gens qui sont en prison qui regardent
cette émission puisque c'est une
émission de refus de une mission de gens
en rupture ne sont pas d'accord qui
pense qu'il ya des choses qui vont pas
bien dans ce pays et donc c'est normal
après tout que 11 ans on y regarde
rien
ne
nous empêche pas de chance
cette lettre vous avez payé pour la voir
oui non j'ai pas payer du jet pas payer
du tout pas un centime je savais même
pas que j'allais va recevoir ouais et en
plus ça aurait été absurde alors quand
collardi aujourd'hui mais il a payé pour
leurs savoirs imagine tu donnes 15000
euros à un mec et il s'accuse de deux
meurtres c'est quand même énorme ouais
toi tu tu accuses de demeure pourquoi
donc donc finalement vous êtes très
surpris le jour où maître collard le
nouvel avocat un arbre châtrices allègre
le 10 octobre dans l'émission de votre
associé marc olivier fogiel et
finalement il déclare que karl zéro a
mené y ait cette lettre quinze mille
euros difficile effectivement il faut
j'ai un cadeau pour sa fille il faut
j'irai lui dit vous avez des preuves dit
aucune mais j'ai envie de le dire parce
que patrice alègre me l'a dit voilà
ouais parce qu'il faut si on raconte
histoire jusqu'au bout patrice alègre
envoie cette lettre ils s'accusent de
deux meurtres il accuse des personnes et
puis quinze jours après il envoie une
deuxième lettre vient [ __ ] la merde
mais ce que j'ai raconté aux juges serge
lemoine et a40 tout ça c'est des
conneries en fait j'ai tué personne les
médias sont comportés comme ans avec
vous car dans cette affaire globalement
si tu veux quand j'ai lu la lettre ils
ont ils ont tous embrayé ils ont donné
les noms ils ont ils ont ajouté des
tonnes par heure là c'était carrément le
délire dans la presse pendant 15 jours
puis subitement hop terminée mais
redescend dit on est peut-être allé un
peu loin quand même et là ils sont dix
qui c'est qui va être le bouc émissaire
de l'histoire et c'est tombé sur moi et
voilà bien mais ça je pense que c'est
parce que c'est
finalement cette espèce de statut
ambivalent me animateurs me journalistes
enfin vous connaissez tu connais bien ça
je suis pas si mauvais en jeu tutoie
allez ça va être plus conviés à un autre
mec ça
et sinon tu ta vie dans un château tu as
de l'argent tu réussis tu vis seul donc
château tu rentres après qu'est-ce qu'il
devrait rester ce soir que tu restes à
on a un petit dôme on va pécho 0
c'est pas du sable entre mc et vraiment
on se comprend tellement bien entre mecs
ont fait pas tout c'est toutes ces
simagrées no 1 c'est après qu'on va pas
beaucoup plus loin sont même pas ça mais
bon on pouvait faire retirer choisit
alors si tu devais rentrer avec un mois
je m'en vais là la petite semoun moi à
oui oui des gens qui allaient tout avec
cette douce quand elle fêté l'unan me
plaît bien
arrêter les gambas excité bêtement s'est
passé
je pense je pense que la petite semoun
savate restait 20 heures à la pire il ya
dire mais je ne dirais pas c'est quoi
quoi quand j'étais petit juliette non
non surnom va péter pts et quoi que tu
aimes pas que je te dise achats pas tu
me fais une scène pupuce intitulé
sourire oui parce que j'étais petit oui
exact il n'aime pas quand j'ai dit plus
ça va plus ça va et toi
moi je regarde lâché bon ok je vais
tirer les cheveux
désagréable
les grandes maisons jean gabin
mes phrases on a fait un truc tu vas
finir mes phrases
et karl zéro tutoyer ses invités
politiques c'est une preuve de
c'est au départ une preuve
d'intelligence à l'arrivée maintenant
ils ont compris le truc donc c'est moins
utile car en cas de pressions du
gouvernement vous arrêteriez de
cherchiez n'ont
parlé du front national c'est
s'est par moments importants ça va leur
devenir la bientôt pour la région paca
notamment le vrai journal c'est une
émission
c'est une émission dominicale
session fleuve c'est une émission c'est
une agression qui n'a pas beaucoup de
concurrents oui les phrases sont plus en
plus compte alors ça va être là car là
est ce que tu penses que car à la grande
époque de canal dans les bureaux de
canal avait beaucoup de [ __ ]
lorsque je lis ou de peau non non j'ai
rêvé mais bien sûr car le matin au
réveil vous vous grattez les cheveux
et le premier samedi du mois à minuit
vous êtes
je suis mis en avant ben non je regarde
thierry ardisson très bien sans vos
lunettes vous ressemblez à
petits talons
bonjour je m'appelle jean louis christ
bonjour il s'est tu es blonde à forte
alors pour les fans du vrai journal sort
la vraie compile quatre heures dont une
heure des meilleurs sketchs de vrais
savent très bien mais se reconnaît dans
les campings dans le supplément dans le
bonus dans le manège que me disent les
deux là la demande malus dans le blick
voilà donc karl zéro puis comme elie
semoun vous êtes lancé un petit peu vous
c'est pas la bossa nova c'est plutôt le
cha cha cha le gars ça sert il ya trois
ans
parce que moi je suis ami avec burt
reynolds et m'a envoyé une cassette dans
lequel il chante des chansons voilà x
files moi je paye déjà reçu des
chocolats
j'avais géré sorti cet album songs soir
cabriolet y aurait ce type aux devils
coolos et aux états unis il a bien
marché et un jour je faisais une
émission aux états unis et le mec de x
files qui s'appelle chris carter qui est
le producteur et le réalisateur se bat
ça ça lui plaît il achète le dise qu'il
est en train d'écrire la dernière série
d'épisodes de x files et il a écrit un
épisode d'après les chansons et donc moi
je vais évidemment pas au courant de ça
je reçois un fax de century fox ouais
vous achète neuf chansons on va dire
c'est pas drôle c'est un coq par m
envoie un gag il faut pas rire avec les
vieux comme moi et tout est en fait pas
du tout c'était vrai et de les envoyer
chez non non pas du tout pas du tout ça
entre en scène
comme x files et quand même diffusé dans
le monde entier on a signé des licences
dans le monde entier chez c'est que de
la frime hôtel en avion jusqu'à ce
qu'elle fait qu'est-ce que ce qu'il aime
les américains et carl qu'est ce que
vous faites avec d'accord il ya eu çà où
il ya eu du bon et donc là on a dit on
va faire un autre album cet été je
voulais faire un album de calypso ah oui
et donc je voulais un groupe de reggae
et mon rêve c'était les wailers
même l'avait fait et je les faisais un
message de maître collard qui nous dit
qu'ils sont jamais les oies lorsque
j'avais touché des 15000 euros promet
bien alors qu'arles votre vrai nom c'est
marc tellenne ouais hein vous le savez
ça
tu te rappelles tu reviens
c'est marc tellenne que je voudrais
recevoir maintenant sur ce plateau on va
faire une interview marc tellenne
[Musique]
mark dm bonsoir c'est la première fois
que vous vous retrouvez sur un plateau
de télévision a ouais ça fait drôle hein
ça fait drôle un peu les boules a pu
être avec des grands artistes comme ça
que je vois la télévision savez j'ai
toutes vos cassettes jamaï si tu as les
six
films j'ai été voir votre pièce bien
sympa
smartphones et le 6 août 1961 à
aix-les-bains exactement comme karl zéro
vous l'avez rencontré quand ce type
c'est mon jumeau c'est un jumeau
stellaire belges et les rencontres et
j'ai même été sosie officiel sous le nom
de marc tellenne de cartes 0 j'ai ma
carte du sosie club international et ils
sont non karl zéro salve est venue
comment ça c'était en 77 un jour basile
de coqs mon frère rentrer à la maison et
dia une nouvelle mode c'est la mode punk
il faut se taillader les cheveux à
l'époque j'en avais s'il réussit à
l'époque j'en avais eu les taillades
immédiatement je suis devenu punk ou si
c'est clair vous êtes appelés karl zéro
et oui il m'a dit font un nom punk j'ai
dit qu'un zéro vous êtes jaloux de 4,0
marque
non non non j'aimerais pas avoir sa vie
ouais non il paraît qu'il a dix ans mais
heureusement souvent sans arrêt il ya
des menaces et tout mais il est
courageux en même temps il est quoi je
l'admiré beaucoup j'aurais aimé être
comme lui
j'avais assez de lui en
fait non je serai pas être aussi modeste
laissez tomber
il m'a pas laissé tomber il pense à moi
ouais il m'a présenté une femme
charmante avec qui nous avons eu des
enfants donc il m'a franchement vous
pensez quoi de la carrière de karl zéro
marque j'aurais jamais pensé qu'il
ferait une carrière ouais bah ouais bah
non seulement ils étaient punk il y
avait aucune raison quoi c'est un vrai
journaliste karl zéro ou pas oui c'est
certainement un vrai jean ministre mais
il n'a pas de carte
4 paires de gants il a une carte tu peux
revenir quand tu veux
marc c'est vrai qu'il a un peu le melon
15 0 il l'a eu il a eu vachement avec la
fesse en fait ouais en 81
7 on a été engagé par francis bouygues
etienne mougeotte et patrick le lay qui
nous ont convoqués qui venait d'acheter
la chaîne ils nous ont dit on a besoin
de vedettes des jeunes et on a dit oui
nous sommes d'immenses stars des jeunes
ouais ils ont dit combien voulait être
payé et on s'est regardés que j'arrive
en a dit [ __ ] il faut demander à un
truc énorme et le plus énorme qu'on
pouvait imaginer c'était 40 mille francs
mais rien ou s'étaient ils ont dit oui
et là on a eu une meule on met vraiment
grave pendant un mois quand on a fait
une émission c'était une insulte pirates
et aux pirates et on a été lourd des
marques très pas qu'il en fait un peu
trop car 0 ça dépend des moments suivi
au moment où est pas tout le temps il ya
un truc qui était riche et carl c qui
perd ses cheveux et vous marque vous les
perdez non mais moi j'ai eu recours aux
implants donc contrairement à 4,0
j'arrive à être fois ça va donner le
change et toi ça se voit pas aller chez
karl plus [ __ ] il sait vous coucher
avec sa femme je lui ai pas dit non
parce que moi je chéris faire lui il est
fatigué et stressé hier soir il est
crevé revient sur
vos journées moi j'y arrive la vincourt
c'est grave et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou